Pat Verducci, Writing Coach, Teacher and Mentor:
I have found when I was first starting out writing
that when I started with a theme like this is a
movie about blank that it kind of became wooden
Film Courage: How does a writer find the
central thematic spark of their screenplay?
Pat: The central thematic spark…oh yeah that's
like the magic. That's part of the magic that we
were talking about I think for me and this is just
my experience is theme comes like almost last.
It's not a spark in the sense of like a catalyst
for an idea. For me it really is something that
comes after I’ve kind of worked a lot and and
basically thought oh that's the theme and then no
that's not the theme and then that's the theme and
that's not the theme and suddenly the theme is the
thing for me that comes last it comes for me as a
writer when I have figured out who the characters
are what they want deeply what their fears are
and as I see them struggling to kind of get
what they want and again it really happens for me
toward the end of the writing process in revision
because I may think I have a theme starting out
and it's never that never ends up what it's about
because as I explore and excavate my characters it
it it appears and it does feel like magic because
for me it's about like oh my god this movie's
really about this I had no idea that it was
about this and I work with a lot of writers
too who think they know what their theme
is and it turns out that what they're writing
is not what they started out thinking their
movie was about and it's evolved into something
else and so that those little things that they
thought were really important at the beginning of
the writing process end up falling away in favor
of whatever is now sort of taking hold because
of the character development in in the story
so for me it's really it's part of the magic
and I don't I don't really even know what my
movie's about when I when I start anymore I just
I trust that I will know and I don't I don't know
I have I have found when I was first starting
out writing that when I started with a theme
like this is a movie about blank that it kind of
became wooden you know because I was basically
just writing to fulfill some prescriptive kind of
tenet or something I don't know but when I just
trust that I don't need to know my theme i'll
wait for it it will come to me usually it does
sometimes it doesn't and I have to have other
people read it to tell me what do you think
this is about because I just kind of get lost
in the weeds yeah Arthur Miller I love this
the way he that we the way he worked with theme he
had this little building outside of his house that
was like his writing shed I'm sure it was really
beautiful so calling it a shed is probably wrong
but he would go out there and he obviously
was working on a typewriter right because it
was the 50s or whatever and he would he would
start writing his plays and he said that in
the writing process he would suddenly realize
what the theme was and it was usually when he
was kind of in the middle of writing his play and
then he would type up the theme and put it above
the typewriter and that guided the rest of his
writing so he would find his theme in the middle
of the process of writing his plays and I'm sure
there are some people who have a theme at the
beginning and are able to kind of write to that
but it it to me it's kind of like it's magical
like it's it's you need to like leave it you need
to let it come to you because I think it's not
even though a theme feels intellectual like
this movie is about this I think theme theme
is actually really like from the heart
it's a heart thing not like a brain thing
interesting yeah so it sounds like okay because
so much of writing seems like there's these rules
and you're connecting the dots to so much but with
this and I'm sure this is hard for writers to do
you're letting it go and you don't know that's
right that sounds like it's very troublesome
for writers so troublesome I mean and and and
obviously I'm not I'm not saying like go crazy
just write everything because it's a balance like
as a human being you have a left brain you have a
right brain organizer holistic intuitive you need
both of them to write a great script okay and so
you know part of it is magical but but part of it
is actually figuring out like creating a map for
yourself so that you don't go out into the weeds
now I know people I know a lot of people who don't
have outlines that's great like if you can do that
if you can figure it out and really let yourself
be completely free which to me is terrifying I
cannot be completely free because I will just
shut down it's too scary so I make a road map for
myself but then if I'm in there and it's like oh
this isn't working the way I thought it would
and this is boring like where should this where
should this be going you know and try to follow
those things so it's a balance of of structure
and also allowing for creative discovery in the
writing process you know so set your your sort of
time your date with yourself to sit down whether
it's longhand or at the typewriter yeah have your
little rituals your offerings have your offerings
and then start writing yeah and then hopefully the
thunder outside the window brings what the theme
is about or like you said you you had other people
look at your work and say what they thought the
theme was yeah I mean when I get really stuck
and basically people come to me when they're
stuck right like they've looked at their script
and they have taken it as far as they can and they
just need someone from the outside to look at it
we all do you know and so I have people who look
at my stuff I have a friend it's it's a it's a
girls group and it's writers it's producers it's
teachers it's storytellers and you know we're
friends it's a social group but we also share our
materials with each other if we need feedback and
it has been so helpful I just I just wrote a
book and I just felt like I i don't know what
to do with this anymore and I gave it to them and
they were brutal and they're extremely smart and
I was just like oh my god this is gold and I was
able to go back in there see what I couldn't see
right because they're coming and so I think we all
as writers need those people like who's our little
circle of who's our community of fellow writers
that we can go to and i'll read your stuff and
you read my stuff because yes writing is a lonely
sport but you can't always be alone you actually
do need people you know and that's the great thing
about working on a tv show because you're in a
room with lots of people now there are issues
that come out of that right like personalities
and all that stuff and I'm sure you've talked to
people who are tv writers who have stories to tell
about writing rooms but like the great thing
about it is you're in a room with other people
and you know I’ve worked as a story consultant at
pixar and one of the things I absolutely loved is
that like I'm in a room with other people and
we're working together on this story which is
not normally the way feature writers work which
is I'm a feature writer so it's it was it was so
fun to me to for me to be in a room with other
people and so you know I want to advise people
like find your group like who are your people
who can you share this experience with and give
encouragement to and notes to and all that kind
of stuff because you can only take your project
so far alone you need other people yeah and so
with the talented mr ripley what is the theme
gosh The Talented Mr. Ripley is based on a book by
Patricia Highsmith and Patricia Highsmith is one
of my favorite writers she's extremely dark
and it's all about twisted human psychology
and she wrote The Price of Salt which which
actually Phyllis Nagy turned into the amazing
movie Carol right so she wrote
about not just super dark things but
but other other things as well but The Talented
Mr Ripley honestly I don't know what the theme is
it doesn't I think the thing I love about the
movie and the book is that it won't fit into
our prescribed little boxes of theme you know or
meaning because the main character is this guy
who's doing everything a main character should
never do and yet we're riveted by him and so
we're able to kind of see the humanity in the
darkness in the dark psychology and so I think
what I'm attracted to in her is that and for me
that's the theme it's like wow monsters are human
too and they are just like me in some ways so
that's why I love her stuff and her writing you
know it's it's so unique and so specific that you
you you can try to kind of like box her in to like
what we understand as like this kind of movie or
this kind of book or this kind of theme but like
she will not be boxed which is what makes
her great but she faced a lot of criticism
especially at that time absolutely and you know
her politics were terrible I mean she really was
was in many ways not a great human being
but as a writer like I have to admire
how she just did what everyone said don't do it
don't do it and yet and in doing that created
these really compelling characters that we
should buy all rights not like and not feel
empathy toward and I think she pulls it off I'm
not talking about carol I'm talking about Ripley
which is a completely different character but
yeah she just breaks the rules which I love.
At what stage of the writing process do
you know your theme?